we spent a lot of time talking about the
left around here but this week we're
gonna be diving into the right my guest
is conservative radio talk show host
lawyer and writer larry elder larry has
written several books on conservative
principles with the focus on government
and racial issues much of his work is
very similar actually to the ideas we
talked about here on the Rubin report
including religion the role of
government and personal responsibility
according to his biography Larry uses
facts and common sense to arrive at his
conclusions that sounds familiar right
now if I use those same precepts as a
liberal can we both be right at the same
time could both be wrong is the answer
somewhere in the middle well that's
exactly what we're gonna try to find out
as I discussed with Don Lemon last week
the media talks so much about the
left-right divide in this country that
it's easy to forget that there are
decent people on both sides of the
debate this is one of the reasons I've
taken the left to task so much on this
show the further off the deep-end they
go the less will be able to find
compromise with people we disagree with
just because I may have different views
on abortion than Republicans doesn't
mean that they hate all women just
because I may have different views than
Republicans on guns doesn't mean that
they're a bunch of rednecks and just
because Republicans aren't for
legalizing marijuana doesn't mean they
aren't fun to hang out with all right
well that one might be true but I think
you see my point
maybe the best way to start a
conversation about political ideology is
to actually define the terms this is
something I've done with a few guests so
far because I often think we're all
talking about different things while
using the same words fear not I have
Google and according to the Oxford
Dictionary here's the definition of
conservatism conservatism is the holding
of conservative principles the tendency
to resist great or sudden change
especially in politics adherence to
traditional values and ideas sometimes
opposed to liberalism all right so I
think we have a nice jumping-off point
they're basically conservatives aren't
big on change and when they are they
want to go about it slowly I think this
concept has been conflated with the
concept of right-wing politics so I even
googled that according to the concise
Oxford
dictionary of politics in liberal
democracies the political right opposes
socialism and social democracy
right-wing parties include conservatives
Christian Democrats classic liberals
nationalists and the far-right racists
and fascists you can see how these two
concepts have morphed into the
Republican Party in America we have an
ideology that doesn't want to change the
system too quickly
coupled with a political affiliation
that is focused on economics and some
level of moral authority interestingly
classical liberals are also included in
that group and the more and more I've
been talking about this stuff the more
I've been considering myself in that
category I'm gonna touch on that more in
the next couple weeks now that we've
laid out some basic terms I think we
have a solid jumping-off point to
discuss all the issues of the day from
abortion to economics to foreign policy
to guns can we find out where we agree
instead of just yelling over each other
I think we can but the only way is to be
brave enough to talk to those we don't
actually agree with if we refuse to talk
to those that we don't see eye-to-eye
with we'll just end up taking an eye for
an eye
you